when our body is infected by a pathogen
beat a virus or bacteria the pathogenic
proteins are the antigens associated
with these pathogens are recognized by
antigen presenting cells they engulf
that pathogenic pathogens and display
these antigens onto class 2 MHC which
could be further recognized by t-cells
now also b-cells with its antigenic
receptor can also determine the epitope
now the T cell and the B cell would
interact with each other and diesel
activates B cell now also the B cell
after activation would form antibody
secreting plasma cell now you know that
every day we are encountering several
different pathogens and several
different paths against several
different pathogens it is required to
form antibodies with different affinity
ability and different types
if this heterogeneity does not exist
then our body would get weakened and the
pathogens would win the war right so in
order to do that our body has several
ways by which this antibody diversity is
maintained and in this video we would
look at several categories by which we
categorized antibodies based on the
differences between them in several
locations first type that we are going
to talk about is a certificate variants
now we know that antibody is a protein
so it would be definitely encoded by a
gene so that is immunoglobulin gene and
the immunoglobulin gene encodes for
differently light chain and the heavy
chain and the heavy chain and the light
chain genes have different variants
different gene segments and with the
permutation and combination several
different combinations of antibodies or
different variants of antibodies could
be produced in isotypes different
heavy chain jeans heaviest heavy chain
constant region genes are used to
produce the isotypes for example the
constant region is very different for
different type of antibodies for example
IgA IgE IgG etcetera now the C mu
portion give rise to IG M whereas C
Delta give rise to IG DC gamma IgG and
respectively epsilon IgE and C alpha
gives rise to IgA so all these different
constant region gene segments would give
rise to different ISO types of the
antibody not only that kind of
differentiate in terms of structure but
also their functions because different
ISO type has different function for
example IgG can pass through placenta
and pair by provide immunity to the
newborn IgE is involved in allergic
response but as IgM IgG they are
involved in complementation pathway and
thereby eliminating the pathogen but as
IG a is prevalently present in a
secreted fluid like breast milk saliva
tears etc and they also help to provide
the immunity in the new worlds so
depending upon the isotypes the
functionality the diversity is huge
another way of classifying
the antibodies is by a low types now the
term allo is somehow related to alleles
and once I tell allele alleles are the
different versions of a gene just like
an android phone so the Android phone
the Android system Android OS is kind of
a gene and different versions of the
Android like jelly bean like marshmallow
these things are actually the LED
gradients similarly our IgG gene
segments have also al aliy gradients
which code for minor differences in
terms of amino acid but they produce
different antibodies now definitely the
heavy chain and the light chain gene
segments are having multiple alleles and
these alleles could generate minor
differences
both constant region mainly in the
constant region of lightning and heavy
chain now let's say we have two
antibodies both are IgG antibodies but
in a constant region they have a minor
difference and as a result their
structure is differing slightly and
these are going to be a low types of one
another because they are encoded by
different allelic variants now let's
just look at the nomenclature of Elder
types now
Naaman creatures are based on like the
heavy chain or the light chain name for
example IgG IgE antibodies are encoded
by gamma right
the gamma constant region so it would be
named as gamma 1m and its variant number
like three to one something like that
and for example that small the light
chain would be uttered as either Kappa K
for Kappa and then M variant one or two
something like that now so IgG m1 and is
GM three these are a low type of one
another
so if we look at this sequence so these
variations could occur at different
region either at the constant region
heavy chain constant region heavy chain
has also made multiple different domains
and also it can also present in the
hinge region between the constant
regions and the difference lies in few
of these few of these amino acids now
last we talked about elio types you know
ideo types are different antibodies
which are produced by different antigens
for example there are two antigens here
antigen a and antigen B against them
against them IgG is produced but both of
these IDs are different and they are
different in terms of their variable
region of the heavy chain and the light
chain this hyper variable loop sequences
are different between two ad antibodies
of same isotype because different
different antigen need to be recognized
by alts minor different antibodies and
their affinity should be also very
different
so that is why ii do types are also
important if you liked my video give it
a quick thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you